Hi, today, I'll be sharing an interesting topic,
the 'extensible design for work life balance,'
that I thought of coming to the platform.
Before I start, let me introduce myself briefly
I'm Lee Jeong Eun, a web developer working at the e-commerce field
The next photo is something I took at JSConf EU
I experienced it first at JSConfEU
I could meet various people
And had great memories, which led me to this spot
It's my first time as a speaker, and I'm very nervous.
But it's such an honor to be here at JSConf Korea and give a presentation
So why did I think about extensible structure?
What was it like before?
What were the issues?
And to resolve that
What new extensible design is born?
And what benefits did I get from this changed structure?
Why did we need a new design?
Please look at this picture,
What do you think this is?
Can you add this spec within the schedule?
Or, I want this function out for this occasion
You hear that a lot at work
I used to hear the same things a lot
In order to respond to these changing needs
My code, unlike my intention,
could be overwhelming with layers of codes and exception handling
Why is this the only way our project responds?
Let's take a look at each
First, the structure without considering scalability
This was my original project structure
The original one is something Dan Abramov introduced
which is Presentational and Container pattern-based
In the early service, the function wasn't too big
The 1:1 component or communication structure didn't matter much
As there were more functions and needs that we have to provide service for at the platform
We faced various problems
First, there was a structural problem in the overall flow
The container component had all the business logics realized
So without using the same container it was hard to reuse the logic
When we needed the same function in the different UI
We had to build another overlapping code in another container
It's the same coupon receiving function
But the modal provided at web
And the page component at the in-app page divide
Log-in
Agreement check
And the actual download logic
The same logic is written twice
With more overlapping codes
There were more uses
So there were more human errors regarding missing a component here or there
And the container component took charge of the most of the business logic
So as the function got more complex, the component size grew
And the code became hard to recognize
With this growing problem
We decided to reconfigure the project design
How did we change the structure?
Before the design we had to consider:
We need to reuse the business logic
The UI and business logic had to be combined with no connection
And the duplicate code should be minimized
DRY is one of the software development rules
It stands for 'Don't Repeat Yourself'
The next flow is the final structure
It's layered differently from before
Let me introduce one background for this design for context
And show you this flow again later
So let's go one by one
For a smooth explanation
Let's say that we are providing this video streaming service
First we analyze the UI component
Like this, at service, we can have UI aspects like logo, subscription button
Video, chatting, and more like that
Even these separated aspects need a reusable structure
Have you heard about an atomic design?
If you have, raise your hand
Many of you have
and I'm sure some of you haven't
Atomic design, based on its name like atoms, molecules or organisms,
is a design system based on the organic structure that combines step by step
Our focus was reusability
So using that atomic design
We took it as the UI component structure
Going back to the example, you can use the smallest elements
such as text, text buttons, icon buttons etc, as UI components,
and you can combine these to create logo or chat next.
You can further combine these to create chatting list or videos.
And using all the above, you can create a page with UI.
I wanted this UI components to be separate from business logic.
If you use UI component that doesn't affect the server data,
you can use the "storybook",
and even without data,
you can test your UI,
and reduce the effect between UI and script development.
Storybook can be published separately,
and therefore, can show the final UI
without embodying the actual functions.
To separate UI components from functions,
now we created a fake component called feature component.
You can accomplish actual functions in the feature component.
The status admin library is a typical example of this.
You can use this as a reference to UI components,
now the server data isn't separated completely,
so the UI component can only show
what it can only express.
Feature components are similar to
container component that was previously mentioned.
The difference is
the business logic is layered and separated.
Going back to the example, say we want to create a subscribe function.
The feature component has
an implementable subscribe,
a subscribe function,
and you'll reference related data.
Let's separate the layer for subscribe function.
I named this layer "action layer" since it is user action based.
If you consider the logic behind "subscribe" action wrapping,
there's "subscribe" and "unsubscribe".
What steps do you think we need to implement "subscribe"?
I'll first have to check if I'm logged in.
Based on the logged in user,
you can either hit subscribe,
or if you're not logged in, you can send them to login page,
and once logged in let them subscribe.
One thing to consider here.
Such checking login function
may be needed in other functions besides subscribing.
For example, in the previously mentioned
chatting function may need a login, too.
If you create the login logic within the subscribe action layer,
you can't reuse the login function in other action layer.
It may create an overlapping code to use the same logic.
In order to prevent this,
we separated another layer for business logic.
This is called a service layer.
The service layer is separated into
the logic related to the actual subscription,
and the logic related to login.
In such a service, logic such as "interested" might be preferred.
In reality, the service layer abide to the following principles.
A service logic must fulfill only one function or
handle unsynchronized logic,
or update the discharged state.
Now the part where you have to implement all these service logic is
the action layer I mentioned earlier.
Using such declared service layers, in the actin layer,
you can create a complicated function
using different services to use it as one function.
Also, when you call the actual function in the feature component,
you can use this action layer to provide connection.
In the feature component, if you only recall the declared functions in the action,
you can simultaneously use the same functions.
If you want to use the same function in different UI components,
you can now only recall appropriate
actions for that specific function
to use the same function.
Okay, let's review what we have said so far.
As I said before, this is the current structure.
The component receives a user action.
Based on this action, the business logic is activated.
Using the business logic,
apply it to the store and deliver it to the component again.
Now the UI will change based on whatever action we took.
If you look at the component box in the middle,
you can see that now there's a added layer
that says "content layer content component".
This layer, when we realized it
If there is the feature component
Functions would mix for some cases
So to separate the functions we layered it once more
With this layer structure out of the need
We can reuse and rebuild it
The project can have no overlapping codes
With some change in or new component
The action and service layer is in charge of the function
So the function already realized can be completed only by assembly
The first structural issue has been resolved
The second resolution,
We had a service we were providing
And that service was the only one considered
So there was no proper reaction for situations
The video streaming service I took as an example
Let's say that we are to provide the version 2020 and 2022 separately
So the product has some different function
And should be provided simultaneously
Previously
Only one service was considered in the structure
Unless the resource is delivered
It was hard to use it in the other page
In fact, even with realizing it in the same resource
The conditional statement like if is always included to respond to the domain spec
In order to react to these requests with each service
As the service increases, the maintenance points do
And the complication of the inner logic increases
It's hard to grasp the spec at once
So how could we provide various services at the same time?
Before resolving this issue
We had to consider the following points:
Now we had to react to different needs with the service
We had to remove the reliance on a specific service
We needed a structure to provide to various services easily
To satisfy these points, we decide to modularize the product
To a moduled product, we used config values
The use, whether it's used
We defined those customized values
Config is provided for the parts that need customization
And to respond to the needs
We enabled the feature flag setting on the functional aspect
Additionally, for it to work in different uses and situations
Handler-type config is also provided
Like this, something I mentioned earlier
JSConf Korea 2020 and 2022 logo
We can adjust the config like this according to the need
Also with feature flag, we can decide on the aspect to use
In ver 2020, the subscription button is only enabled in this declaration
And in ver 2022, title and profile areas are used
And the subscription button, not used.
Inside the module, we make HOC based on the feature flag in the config
To control the use of component
Then, only with the feature flag
The component can control whether that component should be used or not
With the provided options that can be customized
The module can be adjusted to that service
For instance, in the 2020 version I mentioned
Text
And logo color is customized
And subscription button is the only enabled function
In 2020 version
The logo is changed, the title and profile can be used
With one module, we can respond to various services
To provide these functions easily
We provide a maintenance tool separately
So from within the module, the config value set in the admin tool
It's brought in through a server communication
With this enabled active fetching
When there is an issue
We can turn off the feature flag right away
Even with the new function added
We can publish it first without considering the order of publication
In fact, according to the places to supply the service to,
The options to be provided are adjusted
We provide it from within the internal service
So we provide the service using the internal publication module
Including the flow and module structure
Let me sum up on the overall structure
The overall project
In fact, we provide more than one domain
So it's a monorepo
The aspects commonly used in each page
There's the collective shared area
In the area are the UI that can be shared in various domains,
Business logic, or components
Using them, the function for each domain is combined for configuring the page
That's how it's provided
Now, the view area is provided in a module format like this
Could this structure improvement improve the work-life balance?
Here is the review
It's the prototype result with our actual project
Producing a whole different layout page
Didn't take a day
And like this, the various needs from various services
Could be responded only with the setup values
Now we needed to fear no more with more services
Considering this extensible design
Even with new work,
You can reuse the existing logic to increase productivity
It decreases overlapping codes to prevent human errors
And you can only focus on the functions you can actually realize
And even with needing separate pages, you can now flexibly react to it
So the structure improved much more from before
The next wordcloud is something I gathered out of
The impressions our team had with the change
For our team
The UI and Script developers are separate
So separating UI and the logic
The UI developing work got much more convenient
You can see that over here
Like this, to design according to the project early on
You need to spend a lot of time designing
But as time passes, this design shines more and more
Without thinking about this in project configuration, it may be fast in the beginning
But as the service grows and more situations occur
You'll have to spend more time in maintenance and modification
We had the same situation, which made us improve the structure like this
I don't mean to say spend as much time as possible in design
But I am sure thinking about this will definitely help you
I talked about the comments and experienced benefits my coworkers and I had
The keyword for today I intended was work-life balance
How was it?
Thank you
In my opinion, by separating the UI and functions
The reusability improved
With the on-off function enabled
We could respond as a platform as well
Now, even with the same request
We can respond much faster compared to the previous structure
Our project, as I was preparing for this presentation
Went through so many structure and capacity improvement as well
It's a shame I can't share everything today
There are points on better design or capacity too
If you visit me later, let's talk about it together
I think I should replace it with that
And the shared design method today isn't the ultimate answer
For each project, there may be different design that fits
For a small project, this big layering structure ay actually harm you
Likewise, the design for each service and improve through discussion
Since our team provides a big service
The layering for that big service
Is what I experienced and shared here
If, not only our project
But also various projects begin this design thinking
I'm sure it will contribute to the development of the JavaScript world
That's it for today's presentation with the extensible design as the theme
If you had similar concerns
Or if you'd like to have such concerns
Or if you want to give me another insight
Please come talk to me, you're very welcomed to do so
Thank you